When I stretch out of the graph, I notice that I
get more of a cyclical pattern. It's almost like a sine or
a cosine graph. And this makes sense with what the story
the data's telling. I mean, there are seasons in Nebraska, so we
should see fluctuation in the temperature every 12 months. This is
one example of how it's so important to get perspective on your
data. You want to make sure you put your data in
context. Another important point to make here is that the proportion and
scale of your graphics do matter. Pioneers in the field of data visualization
such as Playfair and Tukey studied
this extensively. They determined that the nature
of the data should suggest the shape of the graphic. Otherwise, you should
tend to have a graphic that's about 50% wider than it is tall.